Miss Nagasaki.
Ariana Miyamoto's beauty wowed the judges.
But her appearance has caused controversy...
...after she won Japan's Miss Universe contest.
And some feels she's not Japanese enough.
The 20-year-old model is a Japanese citizen...
...and a daughter of a Japanese woman and an African-American man,...
...which the Japanese describe as "hafu",...
...a word refers to a multiracial or multiethnic half Japanese person.
A film called Hafu looked at the lives of multiracial Japanese citizens,...
...pointing out that about 20,000 half Japanese people...
...including multiethnic and multiracial people are born in Japan each year.
As Japan is considered one of the most homogenous places on Earth,...
...it seems Miyamoto's win may prompt many to question what it really means to be Japanese.